Pope is not a plan in order to have a
real plan there needs to be real rigor
I'd like to approach strategic thinking
in this class by giving you this toolkit
so you can confront whatever decisions
that you have to make
in 2014 DreamWorks had a couple of
movies not work out so we were showing
some losses our stock price was down a
lot and we tried to ask ourselves what
is the best future for a business like
this
and so when you're making strategic
decisions it's very important to
understand the connection between the
decision you make and the Strategic
outcome
if you have a strategy that is your end
goal the decision is your tactic I'm
Melody Hobson and this is Master Class
[Music]